this will be a short tutorial on
infinite series their definition and
their basic properties what is an
infinite series we are given a sequence
of numbers AI indexed by I where I
ranges from 1 to infinity
so it's an infinite sequence and we want
to add the terms of that sequence
together we denote the resulting sum of
that infinity of terms using this
notation but what does that mean exactly
what is the formal definition of an
infinite series
well the infinite series is defined as
the limit as n goes to infinity of the
finite series in which we add only the
first n terms in the series however this
definition makes sense only as long as
the limit exists this brings up the
question when does this limit exist the
nicest case arises when all the terms
are non-negative if all the terms are
non-negative here's what's happening we
consider the partial sum of the first n
terms and then we increase n this means
that we add more terms so the partial
sum keeps becoming bigger and bigger the
sequence of partial sums is a monotonic
sequence now monotonic sequences always
converge either to a finite number or to
infinity in either case this limit will
exist and therefore the series is well
defined the situation is more
complicated if the terms a I can have
different signs in that case it's
possible that the limit does not exist
and so the series is not well defined
the more interesting and complicated
case is the following it's possible that
this limit exists however if we
rearrange the terms in the sequence we
might get a different limit when can we
avoid those complicated situations
we can avoid them if it turns out that
the sum of the absolute value of the
numbers sums to a finite number now this
series that we have here is an infinite
series in which we add non-negative
numbers and by the fact that we
mentioned earlier this infinite series
is always well defined that is going to
be either finite or infinite if it turns
out to be finite then the original
series is guaranteed to be well defined
to have a finite limit when we define it
that way and furthermore that finite
limit is the same even if we rearrange
the different terms if we rearrange the
sequence with which we sum the different
terms